[Music]
[Music]
i remember
the day when it all started seeing this
really strange
thing
a lot of people said an octopus is like
an alien
but the strange thing is as you get
closer
to them you realize that you're very
similar
in a lot of ways
[Music]
it's a hard thing to explain but
sometimes you just get a feeling
and you know there's something to this
creature that's
very unusual there's something to learn
here
i had to have a radical change in my
life
and the only way i knew to do it was to
be in this ocean with her
and then i had this crazy idea what
happens if i just
went every day
[Music]
but you realize that there's a line that
can't be crossed
[Music]
hello i'm ann hornaday chief film critic
for the washington post
welcome to washington post live and it's
my pleasure
to welcome the directors of the academy
award
nominated documentary feature
my octopus teacher pippa ehrlich and
james reed welcome to both of you
thank you so much ad thanks very much
it's great to see you both and i believe
pippa you're joining us from south
africa
and james is joining us from bristol
england so it's a
wonderfully global event that we have
today
this is an extraordinary story of one
man's relationship with an octopus this
is craig foster who we saw in that
trailer who embarked on this
project involving him diving every day
in the water off the back of his home
just outside
um cape town pipa how did you get
involved in this project
so i met craig through a mutual friend
i was working as a conservation
journalist at the time
focused on the marine conservation and
science
and i was very interested in getting to
know the culp forest better
and i went for a dive with craig and our
friend ross
and very quickly i just saw that he was
seeing things
in that environment which i had been
diving in for ten years at the time but
he was picking up signs and finding
animals and behaviors that i just never
dreamed were possible
and he and i started diving together
regularly
and i started working on kind of cold
thermogenesis which is the process of
adapting your body to the cold
and about six months into that process
craig asked me if i wanted to help him
make this little film that he had in his
mind
and the film would be about this very
special experience he had with an
octopus
and he hadn't told me too much about it
but um
he sent me a treatment and i remember
sitting at my desk
and just bursting into tears because it
resonated with me on
on a very deep level and
yeah that's how i got involved
so my understanding it sounds like he
was already
involved with this octopus um and
and this film really really takes us
through the arc of his relationship with
which is lasts about a year which is
around the average time that a common
octopus lives
um and so did he introduce you to the
octopus when on that first dive no so
you were just taking
um and again yeah yes
the film is essentially an archive job
you know when when james and i came to
the project
um i came in a little while before him
but we had hard drives and hard drives
full of footage
that had been recorded during this
incredible year that craig had spent
with the octopus but
she died long before he even dreamed of
making a film about her
it was a very organic
process the making of this film
and the realizing that it should be a
full
right and i guess this is where we
should make it clear that craig foster
himself is a documentary filmmaker and
he had the
foresight and wherewithal to film these
days you know it's
it's almost like a diary a visual diary
and he
took some stunning stunning underwater
photography which we just saw in that
clip and that is
one of the great strengths of this film
is just the imagery that he managed to
capture um what did i read 3 000
hours of filmed material that you had to
work with and then kind of find this
story within it
did you did the um so the octopus
narrative
and their relationship uh obviously
affected you emotionally
um but did you
had you already um thought of other
storyline i mean
did you kind of consider other story
lines
absolutely we started burst broader um
we started with
you know obviously in many ways this the
story
was coming from craig and so many life
experiences
that he'd had had informed you know even
the fact that he was interested in
pursuing this kind of
experience with an octopus and this
daily immersion in the kelp forest
so we started with something much much
bigger bigger and we cut many many
sequences
that we really liked that were very
difficult to let go of but
as soon as we started getting into the
the
nuts and bolts of the octopuses story
that was just
so compelling it was just kind of a
river this just
ran fast and strong um and and more and
more
we we realized that that was where our
story was going to go and where it
should go
right and now james i i want to bring
james in and i want to tell our
listeners that we we might be
experiencing about an eight-second delay
so just know that as we as we embark on
our conversation with james but james
am i right correct that your involvement
was really drawing craig out
craig was drawing the octopus out but
maybe your job was to uh
because craig's story is just as germane
to this to this film as
the octopus
i'm so sorry about the eight-second
delay you
you realize that that's a long time in
human communication um so
yeah i i came on late in in the process
and i think that was
kind of uh it was it was it was really
interesting for me and i'd never really
done that before
um i mean usually you're sort of you
know you're on a film
from the start you see it all the way
through but this is a really unique
opportunity for me and and hopefully it
was
an interesting collaboration for
everybody
because you know pepper and and craig
were were so embedded in the story you
know you know
and and the environment that knowledge
is is so intimate of that place and the
animal
and you know they'd they'd been
working for years actually to sort of
come to the point where
they had they sort of reduced this
incredible year
down into these these amazing sort of
story beats and they they that
accomplished a great deal
um to tell the story um and i think they
sort of reached a point where they knew
they were on
something so great that it was worth
sort of experimenting with with a
different way of telling the story
perhaps
and a new perspective and i was very
lucky that they
contacted me through a company in
bristol called off the fence
and ellen windermeth contacted me
and and sent an email and with a
cut and a link to a customer
and i just thought i had nothing
i know prior information about it at all
um although it was an interesting story
about a
man an octopus and i clicked on it and
thought i'll just give it 10 minutes and
and and see what this is about and i was
instantly
drawn into this um incredible
perspective
that they the the cricket captured
himself but also
that he and pippa had put together this
amazing sort of
sequence of events and an incredible
sort of story around the octopus
um but what was you know clear to me
and them but but they had a different
type of experience on it was that there
was a there was another thread to be
brought in there
and you know i i have some background in
in making lots of interview driven
films and i i also have
you know i came into it completely fresh
so i didn't know the story
so i hadn't lived it for the last few
years
like they had so i had a lot of new
questions and and natural sort of
curiosity for it
and we thought you know here's a here's
a great opportunity to sort of combine
this sort of intimate knowledge and
experience
with it with a sort of a new way of
exploring the story and asking about it
so
i had a quick skype call with craig to
check
you know we just wanted to check that he
was okay with the idea and then
we didn't really talk much more about it
because i then went to
south africa and i met with pipper and
craig personally and we spent
three days interviewing craig at his
kitchen table
and pippa and i talked a lot about sort
of different places we could
interview him and ultimately we decided
on the place he was most comfortable
which is
where he drinks tea and looks out on the
ocean and we were gonna spend a lot of
time there
so we would bed it down and we just
um we took it slowly and we
just asked him about every detail
of how we came to this story and
and and how it impacted him and and how
how
how the whole relationship developed and
and built and
and it took about three days and we were
all exhausted afterwards but
in the end we'd got this sort of really
unique
and and authentic perspective on on his
own
story and and you know he'd been
distanced from it
but long enough the having a stranger
come in and sort of
ask him those sorts of details he was
able to sort of transport himself
back to those moments and sort of re
relive them
as if they were fresh and and it was
fantastic
and you know when i think it we
yeah it was just a really interesting
sort of combination
of experiences that we all sort of
brought to it and then
and yeah the film sort of took on a new
form and pipper and i went back to
bristol and sort of
reshaped the film around that
conversation
[Music]
that's just a wonderful tutorial in
documentary process right and how
important it is to bring those fresh
eyes in at the crucial moment to kind of
bring everything together
pippa one of the most um revelatory
things about this film
are the revelations you know what craig
was learning
about the common octopus and behavior
and
biology um and
you know i think you i'm sure scientists
knew a lot about cephalopods and their
ability to learn
and they are brilliant brilliant
creatures um
but but were you were you
surprised by me do you remember any
particular revelations you came across
in the course of your your work on this
i mean i was astounded i was astounded
regularly and
going through those rashes the very
first time the things that you see
you know when she wraps herself up like
a transformer to protect herself self
from the sharks with
an armor of um shells and stones uh
the fact that the octopus was clever
enough to realize that if she
got onto the back of the shark away from
its its teeth and its head
she'd be safe there uh knowing to
wrap herself up in a basket of cult
learning
throughout time how to hunt crustaceans
you know and that the way that you hunt
a crab is different from the way that
you hunt a lobster
even the fact that every single octopus
has a different personality
and you know craig this wasn't the
friendliest octopus craig had ever met
but she was the most kind of intriguing
for him
i think it was astounding and
some things we knew already but what's
quite amazing about this little octopus
is
she's lived in the kelp forest for
millions of years
so the particular strategies that she
has in her life
you know and they say an octopuses main
driving forces are curiosity and fear
but this particular culp forest octopus
has developed these strategies
because of where she lives and and that
i think was different for octopus
science in general i don't think this
particular octopus has ever been looked
at as closely
and in fact we worked with a number of
experts including
uh professor jennifer mather who's a
cephalopod expert in canada
um she's actually she's known as an
octopus psychologist because she studies
cephalopods and she studies human
psychology
and she came out to south africa and she
watched
every scene of the film with us and and
you know we we
it was always craig's interpretation
that's how the story is told but she
definitely gave us
all the insight that she could into kind
of what the octopus was thinking
at different phases in her development
and
this idea that that an octopus can do
geometry because it has to drill in a
very very specific place on the shell
otherwise it doesn't
uh get the animal where it needs to
these were kinds of insights that that
we couldn't have worked out by ourselves
and it was amazing we had a number of
scientists including uh
dr janis lanchov who's our scientific
advisor at the sea change project
him and craig worked together for a very
long time to figure all of these things
out
you know this is the perfect time to
show a clip illustrating this brilliance
in action this
is um a real scene of discovery let's
let's watch
i remember there was a strange shape to
my left
and just going down
and seeing this really strange
[Music]
thing
[Music]
the fish even seem to be confused
and then suddenly
[Music]
at the time i didn't know i witnessed
something extraordinary
i come in at the end of a whole drama
you think what on earth is this animal
doing
that never gets old um also p.s i'm
never eating calamari again i don't know
about all of you but um
have these strategies been documented
before pippa do you know
right by human beings i mean i don't
think they've ever been
filmed in the wild um you know and if
the kelp forest is a very
understudied area one thing the the
octopus riding on the shark's back i've
seen that
uh it on images of dolphins for example
so i think that is definitely known to
science
all over the world octopuses have
figured out that if you're dealing with
a predator
get onto the back of the head and get
away with the teeth teeth and hold on as
tightly as you can
um but much of i mean
i would say most of of what you see in
this film has certainly never been
captured
on camera before in terms of octopus
behavior
now i want you to tell us a little bit
about the sea change project
and that might that and then there might
be a part b to that question which is is
this work ongoing is craig
still filming the kelp forest are you
still going to look at tell us a little
bit about the ongoing work
so the sea change project is a local
conservation organization based in cape
town south africa
and we're dedicated to telling stories
that
one connect human beings to the natural
world but to
showcase and promote the protection of
the great african sea forest which is
this amazing cult forest at the foot of
africa
what's amazing and unknown about kelp
forests is that they cover 25
of our global coastlines but they're
hardly ever talked about
they're unlike a coral reef or a
serengeti or an amazon
it's not an iconic wilderness that
people immediately recognize
when they hear the word kelp forest and
they're very very vulnerable as climate
change becomes more and more of a
problem
in our oceans which it is at a rapid
rate kelp forests are disappearing
in tasmania and in california almost
entire forests have disappeared
over just a number of years so that's
really what we're trying to do
is is showcase kelp forests raise
awareness about them
and garner a kind of foundation
of global support for these incredibly
magical underwater forests
because they're very important they are
major
carbon sequesterers they contain
innumerable life forms so in terms of
biodiversity they're one of the most
biodiverse ecosystems on our planet
which is very very critical
if you look at you know the crisis that
we're facing today the covet pandemic
that's a direct result
of disappearing biodiversity
so yeah there's another moment i'd like
to share with our viewers which is one
of the most touching
literally touching moments in the film
and it's when craig first makes physical
contact with this octopus that
starts to play such an important role in
his life let's watch this
you'd see a big movement and she'd be
slightly afraid and then look oh it's
him
and he'd come out and be very curious
very interested very curious but not
taking stupid chances
keeping all the other arms attached to
the den
and the suckers in place
and then it just happens i put my hand
out a tiny bit
[Music]
[Music]
something happens when that animal makes
contact
so that moment it's it's very emotional
it's a
beautiful moment on so many levels but
it also raises some interesting
questions about
just the whole um how much projection
that we are doing as viewers and maybe
you
as filmmakers were allowing yourselves
to do in terms of imparting motivation
and emotion to this animal can did you
did you talk these things through and
maybe i'll direct this to both pippa and
then
james after uh after a suitable delay
but pippa did
did this come up at all and how did you
how did you walk through those
questions i mean absolutely
every minute of the process uh we were
discussing it with one another and it
was a conversation that was going on
between our whole team
especially james and i but certainly
craig and i and and
and the greater production team um
you know and there are all sorts of
questions that you could ask but
there's no doubt that the octopus was
curious about craig
that he recognized that she recognized
him as an individual and that she got
used to the fact that he was coming back
every single day you could ask questions
like well
you know did she allow him to watch
her hunt because she felt safe when he
was around because
he'd never threatened her before and and
he was a big
reassuring presence i think that's very
possible
but yeah james what do you think
i think um i mean it's a really
interesting question
like pippa says we we
battled a strong word but it was a topic
of debate for us
all the time or a consideration with
everything that we
we included in the film i mean i think
the the beauty
um of having craig tell his own story
means that it's it's entirely from his
perspective
it's his interpretation of that
relationship
and there are things that he recorded
that you can
see and very clearly happening the
the you you can't really doubt his
interpretation about
some bits but but others are based on
his
interpretation how he what he felt was
happening
and i think that we you know that that
wasn't the reason for doing craig's
personal testimony and making it
entirely
in his own words but you know we
would have had an additional challenge
if we'd been writing a script
that was describing what happened and
and so putting
our own views as filmmakers on it and i
think we would have had a sort of a much
more difficult
uh set of choices to make because it
would have been us
making these interpretations and it
might have sort of confused the viewers
this sort of
these facts and being told or and i
think the
you know craig is without doubt a
great experience and and sensitivity
certainly um but they are all his
interpretations
um so i thought i hope that that's kind
of
clear in the firm we're confident about
those interpretations but it is
it's about his relationship and how he
felt about it and he's the one telling
that story and we don't get
the octopus's side of the story other
than
the behavior that she exhibits and and
the interactions that we can see on
screen so
we thought that was a great and
something beautiful about the film
it did leave quite a lot open to
interpretation
and sometimes we we used craig's
interpretations
and at other times we didn't say a lot
and we let the footage
speak for itself and we left it open and
i think probably
people will interpret those things in
different ways
but i know and people will talk more
about this but
things that we were a bit sort of
concerned about or thought we should
give some extra attention
to how they are interpreted and whether
we include
craig's interpretation or not and i mean
pivo had a
long standing relationship with a number
of octopus scientists that she could
check things from so so everything in in
the film we are confident
is is you know is a reasonable
interpretation of that
behavior as far as you can know about
any individual
octopus at any time but we do
wonder about her motivations because
craig did and and so and the audience
will and should but hopefully we don't
sort of
we're not too conclusive about exactly
what she may be
thinking or it doesn't come across like
that because
you know these are it's how craig felt
about it and that felt like
the most important thing well
that sounds fair i want to get to at
least one audience obviously this movie
is inspiring lots of audience questions
and i want to get to one from patrick
markey
and germany he has he asks did the
filming team join
craig in the water every day and did you
give the octopus
a name this kind of loops back to the
anthropomorphizing question
um we we didn't join craig in the water
at all with the octopus
uh certainly not james and i but craig's
very good friend
uh roger harris who he's been making
films with for years
um is a top top underwater cameraman and
roger lives just up the road and when
these incredible things started
happening with the octopus craig kind of
gave roger a call and said
you need to come and meet this octopus
and you need to see what she's doing
because
i've never seen anything like it and we
should see what we can capture so
there were times when when roger and
craig were filming together
but for the most part it was craig on
his own um
and he didn't name the octopus
and and the reason for that is party you
know
as filmmakers we knew we were in a
dangerous world of anthropomorphism and
we wanted to minimize that where we
could
um and secondly she is a a wild creature
and we wanted to give her
the space to be herself as an octopus
as much as we could
yes um we have time for one more
question this is from tanya krueger from
florida
and she wants to know how has the
climate crisis
impacted the welfare of octopuses in the
area where the film was made
um i i don't know if the climate crisis
has impacted octopuses too much and
i think what we're lucky with with our
particular kelp bars is that it's
at this point it seems quite resilient
to climate change and
our water is not warming up at a too
drastic
rate um so octopuses are doing fairly
well here
there is an octopus fishery which which
we're aware of
um but of course in other parts of the
world when when the kelp virus
disappears and the habitat disappears
all of the other species start to
disappear as well and that means that
octopuses don't have places to hide and
they have nothing to eat
so everything is is deeply connected
and interdependent
well that's another connection that you
make beautifully in this film i mean
it's not it's even though the octopus is
definitely the star but you
you really the the images of all the
other creatures in that delicate balance
in that ecosystem
they're beautifully evoked we don't have
any time left i want to thank both of
you i especially want to thank
james and your patients and i'm sorry we
weren't able to get to you more
because of the delay but we're so happy
that you could join us here today
congratulations on your nomination i'm
sure that's a
thrill for both of you um thank you so
much